ich liebe sie zu sein wir sind hier
germany's next topmodel der philosophie
das klingt nach dir nur
pflichtbewusstsein bloß nicht lachen ich
gehe in die therapie
[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich sitze hier mit ronja
von irene und hier gibt es jetzt gleich
dann einen philosophischen
schlagabtausch es gibt hier ganz viele
zitate in diesen pokal aus philosophie
und popkultur und wie entscheiden
jeweils volltreffer oder voll daneben
ronja du darfst staatlich nachbarn
fangen ja schon sehr nervös ja ich auch
dass man weiß nie was die einen darin
steckt
mir wird schlecht bei dem wort räume das
leben gehört nicht geträumt sondern im
rahmen der möglichkeiten geplant und
angenehm gestaltet aus dem buch wir
kommen von
diesen selbst sieht das kannst du es ist
jetzt gut oder obviously volltreffer es
ist schon ein bisschen altklug
abonnieren die videos nicht zu nahe
treten als in staatlichen vor treffer
weil ich finde leute die das leben
planen verfehlen das leben leben hat
ganz wesentlich zu tun mit unverfügbare
damit dass wir uns überrascht werden
dass wir in ähnlicher offenheit auch
bereit sind fordern eben zu lange ich
finde das schön ist wenn man plant und
auch damit plant dass dieser plan nicht
umgesetzt werden wird oder kann oder das
leben sagt leider doch nicht leider
nicht leider gar nicht aber prinzipiell
richtung schon was gut ist hatte man
sagen hart treffe es ist einfach schön
jean-paul sagte die jugend hat heimweh
nach der zukunft das ist typisch sagte
jedem dritten satz versteht man nicht
schön
erklärt mir pz die jugend hat heimweh
nach der zukunft die alten haben heimweh
das nennt sich nostalgie nach dem was
war die jugend sind sich nach einer zeit
die sie noch nicht gelebt hat kann
mannheim wir haben nach etwas was man
nicht kennt man fühlt sich ja als
jugendlicher mensch in einem ständigen
provisoriums zustand man denkt man ist
eigentlich noch nicht da wo man ist man
hat noch nicht das gelebt was man leben
will deswegen ist heimweh vielleicht
eher eine art wunschvorstellungen von
einer vollständigen identität und die
kann stattfinden wenn du mich sarah aus
der 7b hauptwegen mein haar
dafür muss ich erst etwas länger da sein
und etwas gesitteter sein nicht aber
heimweh nach der zukunft bisher aus
einer lektorin dingen ich bin ein
bisschen älter als du weißt ich darf das
bei head ist das recht auch die falsche
worte schreiben zu dürfen patti smith
super denn freiheit ist die freiheit zu
irren und meinetwegen oder öffentlich zu
irren ich will noch anfügen dass wir
auch bräuchten wäre so ein bisschen in
eine kultur der fertigkeit bisschen
entgegen der kerze coaches wenn leute
daneben sind und das einsehen dass es
dann auch in ordnung ist weil sie es
bleiben nur die übrig die halt so
vorsichtig sind gar nicht sagen dass wir
nur auf der stelle getreten die voll mit
ihr mitfühlen aber gleichzeitig mama wie
cancellara als kampfbegriff benutzt um
sozusagen missliebige meinungen auch
wieder auszugrenzen und zu sagen die
werden hier angegriffen die dürfen nicht
mehr sagen was wir wollen dieser kurs
heißt immer auf beiden seiten offen zu
bleiben absolut und ich finde es sollte
auch legitim sein dass wir nicht blöd
sind sage dass leute sagen das ist
blödsinn fischer
lebe froh und heiter wieder floh am
blitzableiter
habe ich noch nie gehört du schon
lustig liebe froh wie die maus und harfe
troja genau das kenne ich auch der floh
am blitzableiter heißt es dass der
gleich flöten geht oder was was macht
der denn da also alles ein großer irrtum
hier ist ein ziemliches flop dieses
zitat in floh ist nicht am blitzableiter
und erlebt auch nicht froh und heiter
logischerweise da weil er kann kein blut
saugen musste freilich ist gut auf den
sieben robben klippen sitzen 77 die sich
in die rippen stücke sicher die klippen
kippen
moral ist wenn man so lebt das ist gar
keinen spaß macht so zu leben dpa
die frau ist ein volltreffer aber das
zitat moral wird immer so und sexy
dargestellt aber es kann auch irgendwie
spaß machen sich richtig zu verhalten
das merke ich zum beispiel wenn ich
etwas mache was mir persönlich leicht
fällt nämlich zivilcourage zu agieren
also wenn ich irgendwas sehe oder jemand
irgendwie komisch behandelt wird oder so
was sich da einzumischen
mit ganz große freude dass kurze warnung
hier man soll sich nicht in der tram
daneben benehmen wenn du auch in der
tram sitz richtig angehe ich habe schon
mal auf mal bekommen richtig dafür also
würde schon angegriffen aber ich finde
auch grundsätzlich ist das zitat
wirklich falsch weil man könnte ja auch
mal sagen ethik und ästhetik haben
durchaus was miteinander zu tun wenn man
ihnen die anständig lebt gerecht ist
respektvoll und so weiter finde ich kann
das auch ästhetisch durchaus was an sich
haben oder das ist sehr schön gesagt
mein lieblings philosoph immanuel kommt
wir sind nicht auf der welt um glücklich
zu werden sondern um unsere pflicht zu
erfüllen aber jetzt haben die totale im
moralismus keule enorm es ist echt gute
kein volltreffer vor allem nachdem du
sagst ist mein lieblings philosoph und
dann kriegst du den moral kann
oder weil er kann auch der chart woher
die stadt das klingt nach dir nur
pflichtbewusstsein bloß nicht lachen
also man merkt für dich ist es ein
persönlicher volltreffer ich gehe in die
therapie ist ja also ich war trotzdem
nicht sagen voll daneben weil wir leben
nämlich in einer zeit in der wir viel zu
wenig über pflichten sprechen glaube ich
wirklich wir reden die ganze zeit über
rechte und viel zu wenig über glichen
dass wir sagen es vollbracht wollte
verlieren
der schweizer setzte niedliches volk
ich glaube nicht an ein leben nach dem
tod obwohl ich ein paar unterhosen zum
wechsel mitnehmen würde woody allen hat
ja leider leider die eigenschaft es ist
nichts gibt was schlechter altert kann
zum beispiel wenig mit loriot anfangen
oder so ist weil ich ja aber ich möchte
nicht wissen nur rot und wechsele ich
das ist eine generation die arge das
stellt eine generationenfrage und woody
allen finde ich halt eher man unangenehm
typen stadtneurotiker es in ordnung aber
das ist auch wirklich so sein bruder
karl auer also hättest du denn bessere
bord überleben können es gibt aber eine
bessere brannte es gibt es die tat von
ihm er eben die wie denken sie über den
tod und dann sagt er als antwort ich bin
dagegen ja genau das ist schön das finde
ich zum beispiel der treffer also
potenzial zum volltreffer aber das hier
ist leider ich liebe ist gigi zu sein
wir sind hier germany's next topmodel
der philosophie
willen braucht man und zigaretten helmut
schmidt findest du gut findest du es ist
schon ein problem ich bin ja wirklich
wahnsinnig gerne raucherinnen aber und
wahnsinnig ungern vorbildfunktionen aber
hier schon sagen ist es einfach es ist
nicht gut zu rauchen aber ich tue es
halt trotzdem wahnsinnig ich glaube
steckt hier einiges drinnen willen
braucht man um zigaretten dass ich
irgendwie auch deswegen wichtig weil
zigaretten natürlich meistens eine
suchtproblematik damit einher geht die
gerade den willen eben bericht genau
deswegen finde ich dieses zitaten
ziemlichen volltreffer nicht klein ich
glaube dass das so stimmt sondern weil
es in sich so ein bruch gibt wenn man
viele hart hat man keine zigaretten
normalerweise
es ist ein schmaler grat zwischen jungen
geblieben und hängen geblieben von felix
lubricht
sehr gut du als buhmann ich habe ja erst
mal ich finde es auch gut die frage ist
nur ich glaube viele leute die versuchen
jung geblieben zu sein sind in wahrheit
hängen geblieben das denkt ja auch die
die jung geblieben sind weil der
großmutter ist sicher jung geblieben sie
ist 95 weil die immer noch die gleiche
heiterkeit ausstrahlt wenn sie keine
verbitterung hat ich meine sie kann auch
whatsapp aber das ist nicht der grund
sondern das ist glaube ich sich ein
wesenszug gute wesenszüge zu halten
trotz alter trotz allem trotz umstände
trotz sicher mit kommen ich glaube es
ist eine wesens frage und keine ich
ziehe jetzt aber noch bauchfreie tops 71
und zeigt damit frage dieses
zusammenhängen zwischen jungbleiben und
hängenbleiben finde ich deswegen auch
interessant weil man ja auch irgendwie
vermuten könnte wenn man hängen bleibt
dann alt ob man irgendwie schneller weil
man gar nicht offen ist für eine eigene
neue zukunft oder für ein kreatives
autor wie man heute so schön sagen wie
gut also wir sind mal felix recht hatte
ein volltreffer gelandet schöne grüße
und hier ist schon leer ich würd mal
sagen war gut oder ganzer linie gewonnen
ja und wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt von
ronja von romy dann guckt euch die
sternstunde philosophie und wir haben
über vieles gesprochen unter anderem
über trotz als lebensphilosophie viel
spaß
[Musik]